when this project came your way had you
been familiar with the story in this
case did you go into this with
preconceived notions or feelings that
you already had about it or was it just
sort of a vague awareness i was aware of
it i didn't follow it obsessively but i
think that
you would have had to really live under
a rock to not have you know heard of the
case um um
and it you know it was flashed across
the news and i remember seeing the
photos of michelle coming out of court
and her eyebrows and the look of this
girl and she was very much you know the
media portrayed her in a in a very
one-dimensional
way you know she was this manipulator
and this kind of young black widow and
you know it was very one-sided um i
think that also conrad was very much
portrayed in that way he
we didn't get to know him as a person or
his backstory who he was as a young man
he was very much the victim in this um
which he he was i mean this story
we have to remember that it ended
tragically and a life was lost here
um
but it was a very modern story like i
just i was about you know around their
age when all this was going on so you
can't help but think about well those
are young people that are
they have phones just like me and this
is something that we're all trying to
navigate here of this like kind of false
sense of reality that we that we face
in the technological age of texting and
social media and that instant that kind
of instant gratification that you feel
when you get a text and
how easy it is to say things online and
to not kind of see
um
the consequences of of the hurt that
your words can cause and it you know i
think it riveted the nation for a reason
i mean everyone formed an opinion on it
you know and
um i do think that i had a greater
understanding i mean i obviously i i do
now after filming the show and kind of
looking at the story from an unbiased
way and working on it for so long um we
really wanted to
not sensationalize
the story in any way and and show
more to all of these characters to you
know both families and um to just not do
what the media did which was kind of
blanket it in in one way you know and
not show the facts or the details behind
it all so
even with this heavy subject matter
there are elements of fantasy throughout
the series and as a result you have a
song and dance number in this with
colton so what was it like to shoot that
how did it feel to perform that song
with him and did you do you get tired of
it when you have to do it as many times
as i would imagine you had to do it oh
you know this i mean this shoot was a
very heavy shoot every day there was
very intense and i think and that was
the one day where i could feel everyone
felt very light like it was a really
that was one very happy day so i would
have continued we had a great time and
colton's um
so
he's he's a singer so he's like
professional and
like musical theater so that was right
in his lane like he was showing me the
ropes and we had a really great time um
i do love this how the show kind of
balances the fantasy with
reality and kind of the the blurred
lines there because i do think
michelle is you know my character she
kind of lives in between
fantasy and reality a lot of the time so
they use that fantasy device to to show
kind of what's going on in in her head
and and how you know the glee of it all
and how
she kind of was casting herself as the
star in these y.a
stories um
which is just
human
dissection you know to think about
how in comparison was it to do that glee
monologue and the song to the mirror i
mean it's it just broke my heart
watching her do that even though you
also it's kind of weird and you also
feel a little uncomfortable
it's still just heartbreaking to watch
that oh man yeah that was the hardest
scene i think i've ever done in my life
right now
up until this point it was
i i had to watch i watched that clip of
lea michelle so many times countless
times i wrote on my legal pad like every
single mannerism that she did at the
time that she did it and when she got
emotional and when she held back when
she would close her eyes and every
gesture was there so i had to
mimic that because michelle was kind of
it was very meta because michelle's
mimicking grief
but she's feeling grief herself and lea
michelle is
you know feeling grief for her real life
boyfriend who passed away but also
acting on a show and mourning the
character that he played on the show so
it's all
there's there's so much going on in that
moment um and i do think
to hold all that together because you
that is the climax of the pilot like you
have to
there's a moment where you you're
feeling for michelle but then i think
you want the audience to wonder if it
was all a dramatization or you know
there's a bit there's something twisted
inside her that she is mimicking
um
grief and trying to
to kind of
put that on of the grieving widow in a
way so um
obviously we explore that more but that
is a you know a taste for the start of
the series just you know the audience
starts to question a bit what her
intentions are you know which we don't
have all the answers to necessarily but
um and we still don't but we are asking
those questions so did you
have conversations about
you know why you thought michelle did
what she did or
just their relationship and the
influence she had over him when these
are two people that
were rarely even together in the same
room
yeah i think that's what was so
fascinating to us we had access to all
of the text messages
so
reading those were very haunting and
very difficult but they weren't i mean
you could see that there were these two
people were so
in a dark place like they were both
reaching out to one another kind of
reaching out to the wrong people like
you just wish that they had never met um
and they didn't bring out the best sides
of each other
unfortunately um i mean yeah colton and
i we
you know we talked about it a bit i mean
we both are like the same age and
have you know we have phones ourselves
and can understand how you can get
wrapped up in that
um
that like alternate universe that you
can create whatever you want on your
phones i think for us we also wanted to
kind of
destigmatize mental health and
how that is affecting young people today
and especially with social media like i
i can relate to bullying and it's so
easy for people to say things online
they wouldn't say it to your face
um
so
i can you know i can understand that but
you just people have to know like words
hold weight you know like the weapons on
our show our phones like it's not a
weapon but it's
something that was built to connect us
like somehow is
can can be so disconnected you know
so what's what's next for you are you
gonna shoot season three of the great or
are you gonna shoot something before
that yeah i'm shooting um the third
season i leave
pretty soon um but yeah we're going back
so that's a big that'll be a big jump i
mean i shot the second season two weeks
before plainville so i only had that's
two me two two weeks in between which
was
it was like
a shock to the system to do something so
different but i can't wait to go back
that show is it's just
it's my happy place it's so fun yeah
it's delightfully crazy and i love every
second of it so thank you
thank you
thank you so much for talking to me
thank you yeah
you